this ises not clickbait ladies and
gentlemen Marvel Comics just killed
moonight so this opens up with moonight
as well as hunter moon and Tigra
basically tracking down the black
Spectre now for those of you guys who
need to get caught up as always you'll
find a link to the playlist at the end
of this video but Hunter's moon is
basically this like other version of
moonight that we never really knew about
before that Mark Spectre wasn't the only
one to gain the quote unquote moonight
powers from konu is a really cool story
and he's actually a really really cool
character but you also end up getting
eightball right now eightball was just
the super old school villain he was
wildly irrelevant he still is and he
actually flies a giant eightball what
he's really here is more of a
distraction than anything else because
what this does is it allows moonnight
and his guys to get into the building
the reason for this is because they're
on a timetable right black spectre's
whole goal here is to literally just
kind of emit this Sonic pulse throughout
the city that will drive everybody
insane and send the entire city into m
Madness now where that seems like a
ridiculous scheme we'll actually find
out towards the end of this that his
goal is a lot simpler than that and that
it's all just kind of a giant root but
the whole point with this is that it
would make very little sense given their
timetable to fight from the bottom of
the building all the way to the top and
instead they just kind of end up in
there like halfway through and then at
that point as they're making their way
through TIG steps on a pressure plate
and when that happens that pressure
plate actually has a bomb under it so
there's seemingly nowhere she can go now
Mark Spectre of course ends up basically
running off and saying hey like I'll
come back and I'll help you you
literally just kind of have to stay here
because the instant you move that
thing's going to detonate and you're
going to die right so the building is
just kind of filled with traps as for
everybody else characters like Rees
who's a vampire Soldier who's also a
vampire and they work directly alongside
Mark Spectre Reese is sent back to the
Midnight Mission which is Mark spectre's
base of operations literally a living
house wobby TI the poor soul that walks
into that house with nefarious purposes
because they'll basically be consumed
and driven insane by the house itself
it's really cool it's really amazing but
the kicker here is that as he makes his
way through you have of course him
fighting a whole host of different
henchmen and this is one thing to
understand there's a difference between
Mark Spectre fighting some henchmen for
the purpose of just incapacitating them
because they're just kind of a nuisance
versus Mark Spectre fighting to kill
this is the second and he's taking every
one of these guys out with extreme
prejudice right it's one of the coolest
things that I love about Jed McKay's
moonnight right now is you get to see
everything and all the amazing details
that we all know and love about his
character but the thing about this is
that as it all happens zodiac Chimes
into black Spectre Now zodiac was a
villain that was introduced quite some
time ago I wouldn't go as far as to say
was like the Joker of the moonnight
Mythos you could kind of argue that but
he was more or less just kind of a
returned character who was just kind of
like a major Villain at the beginning of
the story but one of the things that he
tells black Spectre is you cannot plan
for moonight right he's a Chaos Agent
anything he touches it completely spins
out of control and that's true right
moonight is kind of the answer to the
question what if chaos in its most pure
form were given a physical form and then
thrust into any situation it's not to
say he's some kind of a Mindless beast
but he's the thing you can't account for
and that's when zodiac tells black
Spectre and let me tell you it's a lot
more fun when it's not happening to me
this time but that's when Spectre says
faith zodiac the plan isn't motion even
moonight can't stop it and that's an
important thing to know here is that
what black Spectre had kind of done
really operating behind the scenes is
over the course of this story the entire
Jed McKay run all these different
enemies that moonight was fighting were
all kind of thrown at him by black
Spectre to kind of weaken him soften him
up but to also work as a distraction so
that that black Spectre could just kind
of go forward with his plans because if
there were no distraction here moonight
would have figured out what was going on
at some point right like someone's
taking out this guy someone's taking out
that guy someone's stealing their
technology somebody wants to do a thing
let's go find out who this person is and
defeat them right and the story would
have wrapped up fairly quickly and so
all these guys are either directly or
indirectly working for black Spectre but
in the midst of spectre's conversation
with moonight that's when Mark shows up
and the cool thing here is there's this
like amazing back and forth right where
like black Spectre says I didn't think
you'd make it moonight not through all
those Fighters those weapons all those
traps I'm glad you did though I'm glad I
could beat you to death myself I've
wanted to take another shot at you for a
long time so that's one of the things is
because we don't know who black Spectre
is even now we don't know who he is but
one of the clues that have been dropped
over the years is that black Spectre has
known who moonight is for quite some
time now moonight has fought against
black Spectre before and I know those
statements sound contradictory and they
sound confusing black Spectre is like a
mantle it's something that like
different people have had over time and
they faced off against moonnight at
different points in time so while
moonnight recognizes black Spectre as a
villain there's no telling who's
actually under the mask and that's where
black Spectre says one of us dies
tonight and if it's you I'm sending this
whole city with you right the whole city
is going to go insane the response of
Mark works for me now one thing I do
want to do here for a second is I do
want to Sidetrack and I want to focus on
zodiac for a quick minute and this is
actually a really cool moment the reason
why is because Zodiac's been sent on a
separate mission right by the black
Spectre and it's actually one that Mark
Spectre or that moonight predicted was
going to happen the black Spectre was
going to send someone after the Midnight
Mission and that's exactly what Zodiac
does right zodiac goes to the Midnight
Mission with the intention of tearing
the place up but that is literally when
Rees shows up hence the re of why she
had been sent back there and the two of
them were kind of fighting back and
forth and and doing their thing and reys
recently did learn the ability to turn
into a kind of mist when she was
training with blade it was only a small
little moment in the comic no we never
got a moonnight blade crossover in Jed
McKay's run yes we're all
disappointed right but it's the one
thing that zodiac didn't account for he
didn't realize that reys had this
ability and so ree literally tells him I
learned a new trick too turning into
mist you're coming off desperate zodiac
and so she says the last time you came
for me you would not cross the mission's
threshold that was a good Instinct
because you're not walking out again and
she says Mission take him and zodiac is
basically taken by the house now how
you're taken by the house and what it
looks like is relative and in fact we
won't really explicitly see what happens
with zodiac himself but he is going to
escape and in fact something really cool
is going to happen as a result of it but
focusing back on moonight right focusing
back back on Mark the reason why you
guys are all here one of the things that
does happen with Tigra kind of wrapping
up these few little plot threads here
Tigra is ultimately saved from the
pressure plate by soldier who before he
became a vampire basically dealt with
like demolitions and stuff like that in
the military so he knows how to like
diffuse bombs and different things like
that Hunter's moon is taking out a guy
named sarak specifically Sydney sarak uh
it's just kind of a little beef between
them but the main show here really is
moonight and black Spectre and the fight
is pretty intense knockdown drag out
because with this fight between the two
of them moonight is tired and that's the
big difference between the two right
black Spectre is fresh this guy has not
been fighting he's not been a massive
conflict he's just kind of doing his
thing moonight has fought himself up
half a building and even if it's not a
full building it's still enough to make
him tired to say nothing of the fact
that all the different schemes and
different things along those lines have
been happening almost back to back to
back to back right like just destroying
a vampire and his entire ilk using holy
water from a sprinkler system right all
these different things have all happened
seemingly one day after another with
small little reprieves in between so was
almost kind of like a game of death type
thing where like Bruce Lee's fighting
his way through the tower all the way up
to the top right it's that sort of
situation right like a gauntlet
basically and so one of the things that
happens is moonight asks the question
why are you trying to kill the city
black Spectre who are you and he asked
this question because historically
speaking black Spectre was never a guy
that would like try to wipe out a whole
city black spectre's Target more often
than not regardless of who was behind
the mask was always directly moonight
and a lot of that's because whether it
is a Warren Ellis comic or a Doug mink
comic from back in the day moonight
stories were never really grandiose in
scale it was never like moonight is
saving the whole world from like some
guy with a crazy scheme sometimes it
would kind of be but once you actually
get into the story itself it's just a
guy that wants to to kill moonight but
specifically with black Spectre his
Target was always moonight and so it's
weird for him to suddenly come along and
to say I want to take out the entirety
of the city right I want to wipe out
everybody in the city drive them insane
kill everybody all that kind of stuff
it's very
uncharacteristic but moonight does not
get a straight answer to the question of
who black Spectre is the answer he gets
here is like I'm a ghost right I'm your
ghost and I'm going to haunt you to your
grave so we could take this at face
value that it's like somebody moonight
has known in the past which it actually
is or we could take it as like a
metaphorical thing right like I
represent the sum total of all these
different people that have been harmed
by your actions different things along
those lines which would be kind of cool
because that was the victim Syndicate
from the Batman comics back in the day
right so again there's all kinds of
possibilities here on who this guy would
be and as we're going through this I do
want you guys to post comments and let
me know who you think it is I feel like
the number one statement is going to be
ra bush
I feel like most people are going to say
that's him but the cool thing here is
that kind of transitioning back to
zodiac for a second this is an important
thing right zodiac does make it out of
the house right he does make it out of
the house in one piece but what happens
here is that he's kind of spit back out
by the house and when even Reese herself
is kind of Taken Surprise by the whole
thing one of the things that zodiac
makes a statement of is that to him it's
all just a giant game because at the end
of the day no matter what happens with
black Spectre moonight can always always
come back because that's one of the
important things to understand whenever
moonight is physically killed that
moonight can be brought back by conu but
but before you leave the video like okay
so he's not really going to die moonight
cannot resurrect he's all out of
resurrections when he dies that's it
there's no bringing him back
specifically because of the fact that
contu was imprisoned he has been ever
since the fight with the Avengers where
moonight defeated konu and konu was
locked up by The Avengers in Asgard he
doesn't have the sum total of his powers
he can't just bring him back and even if
he could one of the things that Hunter's
Moon revealed is that Moon Knights can
only return a certain number of times
once they die the final time they join
konu in his Hall of former Moon Knights
and somebody else is chosen to take Moon
Knight's place so again it's a really
really cool thing like there really are
Stakes here right like this dude is
going to die so it's really really
awesome because one of the things that
re tell zodiac is there are no more
resurrections right like if black
Spectre kills Mark he's not coming back
and zodiac didn't know that because
zodiac and this is why a lot of people
say he's kind of like the Joker for
moonnight Zodiac's whole thing was kind
of the cat and mouse game he chases
moonight moonight chases him and that's
really all it is but then he says like
no like he always comes back he has to
and the response of Reese is you better
hope he survives zodiac because
otherwise you've missed your shot let
the Spectre take it right that is one of
of these things where if you can't kill
moonight black Spectre is going to right
so he'll do it before you get a chance
so again it's a really kind of cool back
and forth type thing here but again
switching back to moonnight himself
right Mark Spectre and black Spectre
what is up happening just because of how
I wouldn't say exhausted but because of
the fact that black Spectre kind of has
the upper hand here in this fight
between the two of them he throws one of
his you know Moon rangs whatever it is
basically the moonight version of bat
rangs is really all it is but it misses
him right and that's when he kind of
gets taunted by black Spectre with black
Spectre saying like you're tired right
you missed your shot and the response of
Mark is no like I'm I'm not as tired as
you think I am and I didn't miss like I
was literally offering this as a
distraction he overcomes black Spectre
tears this guy apart rips off the mask
only to find out that it's Ryan Trent
here's the thing right Ryan Trent is
historically speaking a guy who at one
point was pretty screwed up in the head
but the idea of this is that he would do
on the mantle of black Spectre right and
then he in turn kill mark Spectre and
the Hope was that he would kind of earn
respect within the police department and
be offered some measure of a promotion
it all went sideways and then in turn
became an enemy of Mark Spectre that's
the most recent iteration of black
Spector in in Marvel Comics right the
funny thing about that is that in this
moment when you have Mark talking to
like Hunter's Moon and talking to Tigra
and they're all saying okay like we're
on our way up we'll help you dismantle
the system and all that kind of stuff
Mark gets shot up from behind right gets
shot to pieces from behind and that's
when the real black Spectre shows up
Ryan Trent was a ruse it was a trick it
was never actually the black Spectre
right that Ryan Trent really did want to
kill mark So somewhere along the line
black Spectre approached Ryan Trent and
said hey man like do you want to pretend
to be the black Spectre again and do you
want to take out Mark Spectre of course
Ryan would say yes to that all the while
unaware of the fact that he was being
used for his own ends but when black
Spector shows up here he says your
friends are coming Mark I can't have
that let's have a little privacy and it
detonates that entire section of the
building and then in turn it like cuts
off their ability to access Mark and
black Spectre and so then at that point
the Spectre says we can have a nice
little chat just like we used to and
Mark in turn asked the question like
what in the world is going on here right
like why would you do this like I'm
gonna like I'm GNA destroy you as best I
can but the reality here is Mark is like
like fatally injured there's no way for
him to come back from this right and
even black Spectre says like forgive the
deception Mark but Ryan Trent really did
want to kill you and I needed a little
more time to make sure everything was
ready because let's face it you've been
a real fly in the ointment right from
the start interrupting the work I'd hire
Commodore Donnie planet to do right
basically the very beginnings of this
whole scheme that started all the way
back in moonight issue number one from
Jed McKay's run but Mark spectre's kind
of caught unawares here he's like you're
supposed to be dead right like I killed
you like how are you still here and
Mark's response is like you killed my
shadow cabinet right you killed my
friend you killed Sigman you killed PCO
and his response is plco yes well speak
the devil's name and he shall appear
only for us to find out it was PCO the
entire time now here's the cool thing
about this PCO has been around in Marvel
Comics for quite some time but in terms
of this story he was kind of brought in
as the guy who one interviewed zodiac
when zodiac was in the institution to
kind of understand why he did the sort
of things he did because PCO is a
psychologist right the other thing here
is he says yes Mark I am alive I am the
black Spectre and he says the first
black Spectre wanted the city to love
him my aim is a little simpler I just
want to watch as it goes insane and
kills itself and he says I've been very
good at hiding what I am mark my
interest all the time we've known each
other you never knew and you of all
people should have thought it odd that a
trained psychologist would embark on a
mercenary career in North Africa it's
curiosity mark That's all just pure and
simple curiosity it's like I told you on
hard Island I am a student of atrocity I
like to see all the horrible things
people do to one another and there was
plenty of that in the carac cowboy days
wasn't there but then Le died and then
you did you were the toughest man I'd
ever met the most bloody unkillable
creature I'd ever encountered I couldn't
believe that someone could manage to put
you down so I had to go see for myself
and so this is the cool thing here right
plusco goes all the way back to the
early days when Mark Spectre was a
mercenary working for raw Bushman and
there is an accuracy in the statement
that it's really weird that it never
occurred to Mark Wyatt psychologist
would come along on a mercenary Mission
it's so strange right and that for PCO
himself he really did hide the fact that
the guy is just obsessed with just
insanity and why people do horrible
things he sees Humanity as a kind of
experiment in a lot of ways and so
following the death of Mark Spectre in
Lila at the hands of R Bushman he goes
to visit him right and he ask the
question like are you the guy that
killed Mark Spectre and the response of
wishman is yes right like was he a
friend of yours I'd be happy to send you
to visit if you have a problem with it
right I'm R Bushman I'm the guy you're
looking for but unlike what R Bushman
expected which was for this guy to
basically try to take him out instead he
says like I want to work for you right I
want to see all the things that Mark saw
I want to delve my hands down into the
idea of insanity right into why people
do such terrible things and what he
tells Mark is I learned a great deal
from Bushman he was an artist with the
machete and a kalishnikov he showed me
so many interesting things then later
you and I started working together again
as moonight you left a bloody wake
behind you like a shark now this is one
of the reasons why this is so incredibly
important one of the things that PCO had
done over his time was basically provide
psychological profiles for the various
targets that moonnight was going after
it's the other role he played because
for moonight to psychologically
understand why it is that a person was
doing what they were doing what their
real fears were and all that kind of
stuff it would be a way for moonnight to
kind of overtake this person it would be
a way for moonight to actually bring
their greatest fears to life and to use
those fears against them to kind of get
under their skin so to speak but what
happens is pgo says I am bored with
being a mere Observer a minnow in your
wake I wanted greater vistas of Terror
and atrocity I wanted to put my hand in
my curiosity it was no longer satisfied
with the works of others so I took my
inspiration from you Mark your drama of
masks and capes he took notes from
virtually every single thing that he was
a part of every time moonnight went on a
campaign he took notes studying what
moonight had done every time that Mark
Spectre was a mercenary he took notes
the whole nine yards he was all a part
of this and so once this all said and
done he's like excuse me that would be
the broadcast system it's ready and he
says it's really been nice catching up I
have a helicopter to catch but I want
you to know I've always valued your
friendship goodbye Mark and just leave
this guy to die now in this current
situation it doesn't really look like
Mark Spectre would be killed right I
mean it's just Mark Spectre who's
bleeding because he's been shot up but
this is where the kicker comes into play
Mark Spectre in this moment where he's
dying prays to konu and konu appears in
a spiritual form and he says I cannot
help you my son my power is exhausted I
can do nothing imprisoned as I am and
where Mark says like I'm dying the
response of konu I know you are my son
and you are dying in my service whether
you acknowledge it or not even in your
rejection of me your betrayal you have
distinguished yourself for what it's
worth I am proud of you I cannot help
you but I will await you my son when you
can take your seat at my side so like
this guy's going to die not even konu
can bring him back and instead all he
really gets here is the the kind of
effort and the energy he needs to shut
down the broadcast system because even
if he can't save his own life he can
save the city and so in this instance
where he's like I can't do it alone
Steve Grant and Jake lley appear right
his alternate personalities they show up
and it's like you're never alone
remember like you can definitely do this
man like this is what you're good at you
take the hit and do what needs to be
done and so using the kind of moral
support if we want to call it that of
these guys who a combination of of
talking to him trying to bring him up
but also like screaming at him and
telling him to like get off his backside
and to get up there and hit the system
and shut it down he's ultimately able to
do it right he's ultimately able to shut
this broadcast system down but even in
this recognition that Mark spectre's
dying Tigra Hunter's Moon Soldier right
they're kind of hearing all of this and
Tigra herself has this idea of just like
racing off and trying to find a way to
save Mark but the response of Hunter's
moon is no you can't do that right you
cannot do that this is a Spectre thing
right like Mark spectre's ability to die
right like his death meaning something
that only comes from him and if you run
up there you are going to rob him of
deciding how he dies because his death
is inevitable so let him be the one to
shut the system down let him be the one
to deactivate it let his death mean
something to him and so in that moment
he does exactly that right he gets to
the system he shuts it down and
basically saves everybody in the entire
city of New York but in order to do this
the system is destroyed right it's
detonated it blows up so you get this
kind of amazing Final Call right where
Jake lley is like last cbys it's been an
honor and the response of Steve Grant is
gentlemen light the candles right and
then Mark Spectre presses the button
blows the system to Pieces has this
small recollection right everybody has
these kind of small Recollections of
these last moments with Mark Spector the
last moments they really spent with them
how much he meant to them Mark Spectre
detonates it the entire system blows up
and Mark goes with it right Mark's dead
and so as a final end to this right as a
final end to this let us not forget
zodiac because what happens in this
epilogue is that black Spectre gets back
to his base of operations and he's like
what happened why didn't it work and the
response of zodiac I told you you cannot
plan for moonight and he says you failed
PCO in the super villain game there's a
price to be paid for failure but more
than that you hurt my feelings you took
moonight from me you killed him and he's
not coming back you took what was mine
you can't plan for moonnight PCO but I
have a plan for you if atrocity is what
you want I'm going to give you the full
experience up close and so this last
little bit that we get here is this guy
who's at the Midnight Mission just this
random dude and he's like is he really
gone because I need help and Mr Knight
was the only one who could help me and
the response is yes he's gone and it
hurts all of us every single night he
died doing his work yes he's gone but
the Midnight Mission Remains the charter
the mission that he created remains so
welcome to the Midnight Mission my name
is Rees how can we help yes Moon
Knight's dead but his team carries on
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end let me know what
you thought about this down in the
comment section and if you need to get
caught up on moonight and you want to
see the whole thing make sure you click
this link to the playlist and I will
catch you all later peace